leute ganz groß oft vorweg bevor es
losgeht ich habe mein intro das kind der
eigentlich jeder von euch schon ziemlich
lange ich wollte einfach mal kurz fragen
wollt ihr vielleicht mal ein neues intro
neun jahren anlass auf jeden fall mal
nach oben da wenn nicht schreibe es in
die kommentare oder gibt doch nach unten
erzähle ich das ja und ja ich hätte auf
jeden fall mal bock drauf jetzt viel
spaß mit dem video bleibt auf jeden fall
bis zum ende dran
viel spaß etwas knapp besetzt bekommen
beim videoinhalte ich hoffe euch geht's
gut kommt mal cool apulien roche merck
sagen wollte vielen dank an titus
skateboard shop und so weiter für die
ganzen coolen klamotten habe mich
wirklich sehr gefreut also an die die
leser können der polier ist halt auch
davon ja heute endlich gibt es neues
video
ich wollte das ganze eigentlich schon
vor ungefähr drei wochen machen hat mir
das auch aufgeschrieben nur irgendwie
dann immer vor mir hergeschoben aber
jetzt setzt sich durch mal hin und
erzähle euch die story und zwar also das
ganze ist jetzt mittlerweile so ungefähr
drei vier wochen her ich weiss ist mehr
so genau aber ich kann mich wirklich
immer noch sehr gut daran erinnern
und ja also die die es noch nicht
wussten ich bin schon über 18
auch wenn ich nicht immer so aussehen
aber ja ich bin über 18 und ich habe mir
vor zwei monaten ein auto geholt das
ganze eigentlich aus dem grund ich wurde
jetzt in köln meine eltern wohnen in der
nähe von bielefeld
und ich muss halt immer zwischen köln
und bielefeld hin und her fahren und
wenn man dann halt wirklich fast jedes
wochenende nach hause fährt ihr müsst
euch das so vorstellen an sich liegen
köln und bielefeld gar nicht so weit
auseinander
aber man muss halt immer von der wohnung
mit der bahn zum hauptbahnhof vom
hauptbahnhof zum anderen bahnhof dann
wieder mit der bahn bla bla bla und man
ist dann wirklich immer echt lang
unterwegs also ich war ab und zu
wirklich wenn dann auch noch verspätung
da war über vier oder fünf stunden
unterwegs und das fakt mit der zeit so
ab ich meine du willst einfach nur kurz
nach hause fahren und theoretisch ist es
ja möglich das ganze in eineinhalb
stunden zu schaffen also mit dem auto
fahre ich jetzt wenn es längst eine
stunde 15 und eine stunde 20 keine
ahnung er deswegen habe ich mir ein auto
geholt ich bin auch wirklich sehr sehr
oft damit unterwegs war wirklich sehr
oft autobahn von da an
da oder sonst war es halt so gar nicht
mehr ich kann sagen ich bin auf keinen
fall eine schlechte autofahrer
ich bin aber auch längst noch keine
perfekte autofahrer man lernt auch sehr
viel dazu einfach durch diese ganze
praxis ich habe meinen führerschein
jetzt zwar schon zweieinhalb jahre weil
17 gemacht und so was aber auch selbst
vorkommen ist dass wir mit irgendwelchen
vollidioten konfrontiert wird
konfrontiert wird
das war sie mir richtig hält und damit
meine ich jetzt sich diese vollidioten
die einfach irgendwie mann ist auf der
linken spur überholt halt und kommt von
hinten lichthupe puppen sogar zum teil
keine ahnung so etwas gibt es ja auch
die wollen halt wirklich
schnellstmöglich vorbei halt das was man
unter aggressiven verhalten verstehe ich
meine das beste was man machen kann wenn
leute aggressiv fahren
defensiv fahren vorbei lassen las
gefahren fertig so also das sind dinge
die leider dazu gehören aber über die
kann ich mich eigentlich jetzt gar nicht
so aufregen vor drei oder vier wochen
ist mir dann allerdings die story
passiert ich weiß ich also ich hab die
auch schon vielen von meinen freunden
erzählt und man will irgendwie wirklich
immer darüber reden und deswegen habe
ich auch bei euch diesmal zu erzählen
weil ich das wirklich so
verantwortungslos finde warum man so
fährt und ja keine ahnung also ich war
in dem moment wirklich für die nächste
halbe strecke geschickt und zwar bin ich
halt von mir zuhause zu hause also ich
wenn mein zuhause in köln zu hause und
mein anderes zuhause zu hause zu hause
also kurze informationen damit die den
kontext hat versteht ich bin von zu
hause zu hause also von meinen eltern
aus je nach zu hause gefahren
wenn sie nach köln und ich war gar nicht
mehr lange unterwegs sagen so 20 minuten
und die autobahn verläuft und halt an
zwei stellen miteinander relativ bald
geradeaus sie wird zu sagen es geht also
ab kilometer geradeaus breite strecke
alle fahren war relativ schnell der ist
vielleicht ganz wichtig ich fahre ich
mal sagen so im durchschnitt wenn ich
jetzt nach köln fahren weil die autobahn
würde ich mal sagen so 160 km h das ding
ist halt in einem sportwagen kommt einem
das ganz so schnell vor wittmann sagen
wenn ich jetzt 160 oder 170 mit meinem
auto fahre wirkt das sowie 120 mit einem
anderen auto oder so
familienauto wisst was ich meine halt
einfach wie mit so einer familienkutsche
keine ahnung ihr müsst euch die
situation so vorstellen ich war ungefähr
so in der mitte
500 meter vor mir war nichts also die
nächsten autos waren zu 500 meter
entfernt war aber relativ voll dann
wieder und hinter mir war auch nicht so
viel war ob ich da so alleine über keine
ahnung war halt so dass es passiert ja
manchmal so natürlich in deutschland
herrscht ja rechtsfahrgebot ich fahre
meistens dann in der mitte oder halt
ganz rechts in dem fall bin ich dann in
der mitte gefahren der situationsbedingt
bin ich das weiß noch ganz genau
halt ich habe keine ahnung irgendwie
noch wenn autos vorbeigefahren bin dann
in die mitte gezogen als ich war auf dem
mittleren fahrstreifen und sind haben
wir was relativ leer wichtig ist ja
immer auf der autobahn dass man ab und
zu mal in einem spiel geschaut um zu
sehen was hinter einem floß und ich habe
dann halt reingeschaut und hab so von
hinten gesehen dass ich relativ schnell
zwei sportwagen also man hat das schon
gesehen die waren relativ schnell flach
gelegt so merten
und ja ich bin zu dem zeitpunkt zu 160
165 km h gefahren also gar nicht mal so
langsam aber die kam wirklich aber die
kamen wirklich sehr sehr schnell näher
und ich weiss nicht als ich sie so
gesehen habe würde ich sagen war nie so
sind kilometerweit von mir weg jetzt mal
grob geschätzt aber die waren dann
außerhalb von 25 sekunden oder nach
halben minute fast beim dhc hatten
bestimmt so tempo 230 240 drauf ich
meine gut in deutschland können sie so
schnell fahren wie du willst mich
wundere mich sowieso manchmal wenn man
dann mal etwas schneller fährt was ist
für leute gibt dass die dann noch mal
mit so einem richtigen affen zahl an dir
vorbei sind wo man denkt alter fast 300
ich ich könnte das gar nicht ich will
mir da ich will mir das so in die hose
pissen ja nochmal ganz kurzen zeit waren
jan plötzlich wirklich hinter mir und
ich dachte ja die falle zwischen einfach
an mir vorbei ja so kam es aber nicht
die beiden sind nicht einfach an mir
vorbeigefahren was man vielleicht mal
kurz sagen kann oder was ich so merkte
seitdem ich das auto ab viele schauen
halt wirklich immer hinterher oder
schauen rein natürlich ist es ein
schönes auto aber es ist jetzt auch kein
mega ferrari für
200.000 euro oder so man merkt schon
dass man relativ häufig angeschaut wird
wollen wir dann auch noch so ein bisserl
drin sitzt wie ich wo sich die meisten
wahrscheinlich fragen her hat er schon
führerschein und dann passierte
folgendes also die sind halt nicht
einfach an mir vorbeigefahren
das waren halt zwei sportwagen habe ich
ja schon gesagt wer eigentlich hatte es
danach mal nachgeguckt war glaube ich
einen porsche 918 spyder also der ist
schon echt fett und das andere waren
maserati was genau kann ich jetzt nicht
sagen ich kenne mich jetzt auch nicht so
super mit autos aus der porsche ist
links dem ich gefahren und der maserati
es halt hinter mir es vorgezogen auf die
rechte spur und das rechts neben mir
gefahren ich war in der situation so ein
bisschen verwundert und habe jetzt auch
nicht so mega darauf geachtet werde
jetzt drin saß aber es waren auf jeden
fall so zwei männer hier müssten so
zwischen 25 und 35 gewesen seien keine
ahnung ich kann es nicht genau
einschätzen ich habe nur drüber geguckt
weil die halt wirklich komplett neben
mir gefahren sind vor und zwar nichts
500 meter weit und hinter uns auch nicht
das heißt das muss man sich vorstellen
wie bei fast and furious drei autos
nebeneinander auf der straße die freies
bewegen sicherheit mit der gleichen
geschwindigkeit voran
von oben sieht das bestimmt teil aus so
und ich also in der mitte gibt darüber
und ich schauten sich halt durch mein
auto praktisch an
das habe ich wirklich gesehen dass die
sich halt kann die hatten auch das
gleiche nummernschild schöne grüße kreis
warendorf der kreis ist bei uns um die
ecke
ich habe mal so das gefühl keiner von
denen kein auto fahren also wenn ihr das
seht hier nur wenn du jetzt gerade aus
diesem kreis kommst fühle ich mich
persönlich angegriffen
du bist nicht der einzige der kein auto
fahren so wie schon gesagt ich halte in
der mitte hat sie keine ahnung ich hatte
wirklich so ein bisschen angst weil ich
ich wusste nicht was wollen wir jetzt
von mir warum fahren sie so genau neben
mir mir ist dann halt irgendwann so klar
geworden dass das jetzt kein zufall ist
sondern dass sie wirklich bewusst
irgendwie mich praktisch ein kessel
möchten oder keine ahnung wie ich nennen
soll so die erste frage die ich mir
stelle
warum macht man so was an sich weiß wer
komplett logisch für mich gewesen sei
ist jetzt zum beispiel mädel drin 18
jahre oder so gerade den führerschein
das dann halt ein panik entsteht oder
dass man halt nicht weiß was wollen
diese männer jetzt von mir warum fahren
die warum kommt mit seinem affenzahn an
gras und christel mich dann ein ja also
an sich keine gefährliche situation nur
es kann ja was gefährlich ist daraus
entstehen wenn man jetzt vielleicht
dadurch angst bekommt oder sowas und die
sind halt neben mir gefahren und das war
nicht einfach nur zehn sekunden die die
neben mir gefallen das war wirklich so
eine minute eine minute 30 keine ahnung
die von halt die ganze zeit neben mir
und ich war halt ich wollte schon immer
etwas ich dachte mir was wollen die von
mir und das hat dann halt irgendwie spaß
gemacht mich das so zu sehen und sich
gegenseitig so anzugucken und sich so an
zu grinsen mit ihren autos ich weiß aber
dass die ab einem bestimmten zeitpunkt
einfach nur noch nach vorne geschaut
habe und habe immer ein bisschen
abgebremst ich waren irgendwann so bei
100 120 nur noch die beiden haben halt
wirklich mit mir abgebremst und war dann
auch irgendwann nur noch 300 die wollten
mich halt wirklich ärgern so das hat man
richtig gemerkt dass das spaß macht so
mehr angst einzujagen oder keine ahnung
was eure mission war wenn ihr das seht
hier das verlust ich bin auch so eine
dritte hand von unten kommen noch vor
zwei jahren
wir haben uns mit der zeit dann aber den
autos die vor uns waren relativ
angenähert also die waren gar nicht mehr
so weit von uns weg auch wenn ich dann
irgendwann abgebremst habe dann hat sich
der abstand natürlich wieder ein
bisschen vergrößert aber wir waren
relativ nah dran also es waren keine 500
meter mehr
ich wollte halt erst auf eigentlich den
anderen autos nahe kommen damit die sich
vielleicht ein anderes opfer aussuchen
oder einfach weiterfahren oder andere
leute halt darauf aufmerksam werden
obwohl das wahrscheinlich ziemlich
schwer gewesen wäre weil ich meine hätte
ja auch sein können dass ich dazu gehöre
von den autos herz gepasst wo man so
traurig es auch ist ich finde das so
verantwortungslos abkommen hier der
alten mustern ist etwas jünger
mit dem kann man so ein rennen machen
also es war wirklich verdammt danach aus
so wenn ich jetzt im nachhinein über
nachdenken ja und nach ungefähr einer
minute oder eineinhalb minuten revan hat
langsam nur noch 100 km h oder so der
porsche fahrer und der maserati fahrer
die haben sich angeschaut und man hat so
irgendwie gesehen jetzt vielleicht
passiert irgendwas oder ein handy und
dann haben die plötzlich beide
heftig drauf gedrückt und der porsche
das war einfach so fucking laut weil der
wagen eben hier und beschleunigt
irgendwie von 100 widerhallt von drei
sekunden auf 200 zu gefühlt der maserati
fast genauso schnell also um mich rum wo
es richtig richtig laut ich habe mich
richtig erschrocken und dann zieht der
porsche kurz weg genau vor mir also das
war jetzt wirklich keinen
sicherheitsabstand von 15 meter ich
würde sagen das waren so fünf meter ab
zieht davon und der maserati auch genau
vor mir also die sind dann halt so
praktisch so an mir vorbeigefahren und
dann so zusammen und dann weg und die
war unfassbar schnell also ich glaube
die haben innerhalb von zehn sekunden im
tempo von 250 erreicht oder so und wie
die dann gefahren sind echt gleich
passiert dann unfall die sind einfach da
waren drei autos nebeneinander oder sag
ich mal so gestaffelt und ich meine die
autobahn hat nur drei spuren und der
porsche ist durch die ganz kleine lücke
durchgezogen wird zum richtigen karaffen
tempo karaffen tempo sagt man das und
das hat mich wirklich dann so richtig
aggressiv gemacht weil ich meinen wie
kann man so verantwortungslos seien
stelle die vorder wie eine familie
gewesen oder so und weil du so nah dran
vorbei gezogen ist
was passieren können der hat hier
einfach aus reflex ist auto nach rechts
ziehen können wenn unfall passiert viele
leute tot ja geil so was verstehe ich
halt nicht warum man so fährt dinger
keine ahnung ich habe mich von dem
porsche auch das nummernschild gemerkt
nur an sich kann ich ja nicht viel
machen ich meine dann müsste das schon
mehrere leute bei der polizei zu melden
denke ich mal nur ich war nach dieser
situation wirklich für 30 minuten so ein
bisschen krass da hätte jetzt echt
meiner meinung nach was passieren können
weil man so fährt er das sind dann halt
so leute wie wenn sie dann unter bauen
hoffentlich ein unfall alleine bauen und
keine zehn leute mit rein
so hat sich das jetzt auch anhören mag
deswegen das wollte ich einfach mal
erzählen passt immer auch vorsichtig
lass einfach alle die meinen wir müssen
aggressiv fahren einfach dran vorbei
ziehen und dann macht ihr auto fahren
auf mega spaß aber es gibt halt diese
vollidioten also wenn du so einer bis
über denk mal deine fahrweise leute das
war's mit der story ich hoffe ihr habt
jetzt zugehört wenn ja dann lass mal
genau jetzt den daumen nach oben dann
sehe ich das ja und wir sehen uns dann
morgen wieder
morgen gibt's neues video chats netz ist
ganz wichtig